last night u.s president biden held a
marathon two-hour press conference at
the white house to mark his first year
in office he said what was uncomfortable
and obvious nato is not always unified
over what to do about russia and he
threw confusion on top of that by
suggesting the u.s and his allies might
react differently to a minor incursion
into ukraine by russia as opposed to a
full-scale military invasion his press
secretary has spent the past 24 hours
explaining what her boss meant to say
and on this side of the atlantic it was
cleanup duty as well for u.s secretary
of state anthony blinken on a stop here
in berlin today he once again reassured
kiev and u.s allies in europe that the
uf stance remains unchanged any russian
move against ukraine will result in
severe consequences
period
the stakes are high u.s secretary of
state anthony blinken landing in berlin
to try and rally america's allies and
prevent a war
unity is the main goal here blinken and
his german french and british
counterparts discuss the intense fears
that russia may soon invade ukraine
their focus how to credibly deter moscow
with warnings of what could follow
even as we're relentless in pursuing
this diplomatic path
we'll continue to make very clear that
if moscow chooses the path of further
aggression
we will impose swift and massive costs
we urgently call on russia to take steps
towards the escalation
any further aggression would have
serious consequences
but comments by the us president a day
earlier have raised questions about
whether those consequences really do
apply to any act of aggression
russia will be held accountable
if it invades and it depends on what it
does it's one thing if it's a minor
incursion and then we end up having to
fight about what to do and not do etc
but if they actually do what they're
capable of doing with the force of mass
on the border it is going to be a
disaster for russia
the white house later tried to clarify
insisting that the west would react come
what may but the issue has highlighted
questions over what level of aggression
would trigger what kind of response the
u.s has made it clear that it would
expect berlin to target the
controversial nordstream 2 pipeline
which links germany to russian gas
it's also worth noting that gas is not
flowing through nordstrom 2 yet which
means that the pipeline is leveraged
for germany the united states and our
allies not russia
for now though there's another round of
diplomacy coming up anthony blinken will
meet his russian counterpart in geneva
on friday seen as one of the last
chances to find a way of avoiding war
we have team coverage of this story
tonight our washington bureau chief enos
po she joins us from the u.s and our
chief international correspondent
richard walker he is here with us in
berlin
to both of you good evening let me start
with you richard when it comes to
dealing with russia in ukraine just how
unified is the west
well there's been a pretty strong show
of unity from the western allies uh on
during this crisis so far brent um
even to the extent that there was
evidence of some exasperation by the
russian side last week during the you
know the first intense round of
diplomacy that began last week where
first of all they met the americans then
they met all of the nato member states
then they met the members of the wider
organization for security and
cooperation in europe the osce last week
it was sort of exasperation at the sort
of unity of the message that was being
played back at them to the extent that
by the end of last week the russians
were almost saying well we're not sure
if we want to keep talking at all
but this unity will certainly get tested
uh in the weeks ahead particularly if
the russians do move ahead with with
some further aggression against ukraine
and on a couple of
uh questions as we just heard in the
piece there you know what degree of
aggression leads to what degree of
reaction the kind of thing that biden
was was raising in those comments that
caused such an outcry that is a genuine
question especially here in germany for
the social democrat party which has
always been trying to
keep close connections with russia plus
how to respond to the bigger russian
demand of a total rethink of this sort
of european security order there the
french president yesterday seemed to be
going off on his own track so we'll have
to see how far that unity does hold and
enos you know we heard the president
last night throwing some doubts on
allied unity i mean just how satisfied
is washington with the position of its
european allies
well president biden is really in a
tough spot right here brent on the one
side domestic political pressure builds
up both parties have indicated that they
have very different approaches
when it comes to russia russia and on
the other side there is europe in
germany with very mixed messages
at least in the beginning of the crisis
at the ukrainian border
however as richard just pointed out i do
think that over the course of the last
days the message from germany is a
little bit clearer actually also within
germany if
putin really invades ukraine he will
face harsh sanctions and you know last
night biden was asked about ukraine's
geography
the fact that it borders nato members as
well as russia and how that should be
included in any calculus in the kremlin
regarding an invasion take a listen to
what he said
the only war that's worse than one
that's intended is one that's unintended
and what i'm concerned about
is this could get out of hand
very easily get out of hand because of
what you said the borders of the of
ukraine and what russia may or may not
do i am hoping that
vladimir putin understands that he is
short of a full-blown nuclear war he's
not in a very good position to dominate
the world
to dominate the world but let's look at
the facts here richard we've got a
hundred thousand russian troops
positioned on the border with ukraine
we had ukraine's president last night
telling his country to exhale and to
turn down the level of worry how
concerned is the west of a war breaking
out by accident
yeah well there are two things we're
talking about here of course we've we're
talking about the potential invasion by
by the russians of ukraine and and then
what biden is referring to this this
fear of accidental war that this could
potentially spill over
um
to a wider conflict with nato and i mean
these concerns are real
uh ukraine has borders with four nato
countries belarus which may get drawn
into this conflict
putin has been sending russian troops
there too that has borders to two more
nato countries all of those nato
countries are going to feel extremely
vulnerable if a conflict does break out
they're going to be wanting a
reinforcements to come in from nato
so
you're likely to see a sort of a piling
of troops into the region from the nato
side and this does raise of course the
prospect of some potential clashes down
the road whether they're intended at
this point or not so genuine fears there
yeah and you know enos to take it to you
even if joe biden had
hawkish hands which we know he doesn't
they would be tied because americans are
simply tired of foreign wars there is no
willingness to go to war over ukraine is
there
no not at all brendan i'm
traveling the country quite a bit and i
also try to talk a little bit politics
with the people when i talk when i
report on other topics and no there's
definitely no a will to start a new war
to get involved
with with russia even you know we have
to keep in mind uh
the cold war is long over and people mem
people's memories are short people are
much more concerned about
china these days than about russia and
quite frankly if you would ask an
average american
where ukraine or belarus or other
countries that would be
on the map they wouldn't even be able to
show you where they lie yeah that is
that's a good point edis you know we're
talking about a superpower that is
overstretched abroad and under invested
at home that is the united states that
joe biden says he inherited from donald
trump biden has now been in office
exactly one year as of today i'd like us
to put together a first year report card
for president biden tonight and we're
going to start by taking a look back at
what he did in his first year and most
importantly how he did what he did
hi joseph robinette biden jr do solemnly
swear one year ago large parts of the
western world breathed a sigh of relief
not so much because of the new occupant
the white house president joe biden a
long-term figure in washington with
almost a half a century of policy making
experience
but because they hoped that the chaotic
chapter that was the donald trump
experiment would soon be at an end
david marinus is an award-winning
journalist and a presidential biographer
he was clearly the right person for the
job a year ago he was probably the one
democrat who could get elected and stop
the trump descendants
but now a year later there are real
questions about that about whether he's
the right person for the next three
years
to start with the positives in his first
year in office president biden was able
to push a one trillion dollar
infrastructure package through congress
a feat that no president had been able
to accomplish in 60 years
but its impact won't be felt for a long
time and people might not reward him
with their vote in 2024
what they do feel immediately are the
increasing prices for basic goods
inflation has risen at its fastest pace
in nearly four decades pushing prices up
at a seven percent annual rate
for the international community the
chaotic withdrawal from afghanistan
raised many questions especially about
how closely the new white house is
really willing to work together with its
nato partners
one two three like most parts of the
world dealing with the kovit 19 pandemic
is a major challenge with midterm
elections coming up in november biden is
in danger of losing his race of thin
majority in the senate and in the house
biden has to walk a fine line between
protecting the american people and
scaring or ignoring the concerns of
possible voters
mr president with his approval rating at
an all-time low with 65 percent of
americans believing his presidency is a
failure what could the next steps be
requires more than just joe biden
requires the entire democratic party to
get its act together which it hasn't
been able to do in this last year and
getting some luck on the pandemic i mean
some of it is beyond his control
even one of the most powerful
politicians in the world faces severe
limits to pushing through his agenda
[Music]
and enos you know most u.s presidents in
their first year if they are lucky they
are able to get one piece of measure
major legislation through congress in
their first year joe biden he got two i
mean you said it the coveted rescue plan
the infrastructure bill why isn't he
bragging about these accomplishments and
why aren't his fellow democrats in
congress why aren't they bragging about
this as well
well the problem is brent as we just
heard in the piece it's really it will
take years probably before people
really feel the outcome of the
infrastructure
package i'm sure that the history books
will write about that in 10 20 30 years
but for now
people don't feel that that is a problem
and it is um also a problem with covet
19 i think it's fair to say that joe
biden did do many things right in the
beginning he probably
failed on putting out enough testing
kits to the people but he provided a
country
with the possibility to get vaccinated
without any preparation because
president donald trump didn't leave any
plan however this is nothing
people will remember but what they feel
is the
inflation rate and they also see kind
the internal fights of the democratic
party and this is everything or all that
is
joe biden is blamed for that
maybe unfortunately so yeah and we want
to be fair here i mean biden is faced
with a republican party that has
obedience to donald trump on its mind
not compromise with the democrats on its
mind i want you to take a listen to what
biden said about the gop last night
i did not anticipate that there'd be
such a
stalwart effort to make sure
that the most important thing was that
president biden didn't get anything done
think about this what are republicans
for
what are they for
they mean one thing they're for
you know richard joe biden there he
sounds as if he didn't reckon with
republican blockades while you i enos
the rest of the world we reckoned with
that
biden came to the white house with the
most experience more experience under
his belt than any president in modern
history how do you explain this
this apparent naivete regarding the
republicans
yeah well i don't think it's naivety
really brent i think he just has to say
that he sees no alternative the
alternative would be simply to say to to
sort of suggest that he himself is to
blame for for these failures
and of course i mean we all remember you
know he's had a very long career but of
course you know the last big ticket on
his career was being vice president to
barack obama and the last couple of
years of that at the very least were
totally hobbled by republican
obstructionism so
of course he would have expected this to
happen but i think at the moment he's so
under fire that of course you know this
is pretty much the explanation he has to
offer enos you know as frustrating as it
is i mean you know you deal with this um
a lot traveling across the united states
what do everyday
americans what do they tell you
when you ask about biden's inability to
break through the political paralysis in
washington
i think a lot of americans are
discouraged about american politics
overall you know i mean depending where
people sit politically some certainly
will blame the president for the lack of
movement and how congress has stalled
almost every piece of legislation and
people who sit on the left are
definitely disappointed because they
believed that they had a moment to make
history by passing
social policy and and voting rights
um but obviously many really
underestimated the divide in the party
between in the democratic party between
moderates and progressives
and that the razor thin majority was way
more significant than they believed
one thing uh
brenda always experienced and that is i
think really worrisome is that more and
more really
more and more people really turn their
back towards politics
they don't care anymore they're not
interested anymore they're so tired of
that and i think this really
is a huge threat for this democracy here
yeah i i agree with you i think it's
it's a big threat to democracies
everywhere let's um broaden the scope of
biden's first year in office and place
it in a global context i want you to
listen to what he said last night
regarding the 21st century struggle
between democracies and autocracies
unless you can reach consensus in a
democracy
you cannot sustain the democracy
and so this is a real test
whether or not
my
my
uh
my counterpart in china is right or not
when he says autocracies
are the only thing they're going to
prevail because democracies take too
long to make decisions and countries are
too divided
i believe we're going through one of
those inflection points
in history
inflection points in history enos
president biden sounds like a man who
may
harbor
secret doubts about democracy winning
the day and the century against the
forces of china
russia
and and company
do you agree
well you know for biden i think we
always have to imagine only days before
he took office thousands of trump
supporters really scaled the walls of
congress
because they believed the election was
stolen and the former president
attempted essentially a political coup
to stay in office and this is something
i think joe biden is still
kind of shaped by and he's
still
shaken by
so um
he won't forget that
and i think
that he fears that the institutions that
once held the united states as the
so-called beacon of democracy are not a
certain ground anymore
so he definitely is watching his own
country struggling to keep a democracy
upright and there are many signs uh yeah
which lead in that direction so yes
indeed i think he is not betting on the
future of democracy in this country yeah
i mean that's it's really sad it's
certainly not encouraging richard let's
talk more about this inflection point in
history i mean it implies a process
that's not complete we are perhaps in
the middle of it we don't know how it
will look on the other side talk to me a
little bit about the position of biden's
america in this inflection
yeah well it is funny bradley i would
agree with everything he just said just
there and
biden was talking about this inflection
point he raised it a couple of times in
speeches last year as well and
at some length in his press conference
last night too and was quite interesting
some of this really overlaps with what
xi jinping was saying earlier in the
week to the world economic forum saying
that this is a period where the world is
going
undergoing very very intense change and
i think there is where biden and xi
jinping the chinese leader would
absolutely agree but i think
from the us perspective this the
greatest danger certainly is internal
that you have in the u.s a political
system that is really
struggling to deal with these kind of
twin challenges from society on the one
hand and from technology on the other
hand which are fueling this this
incredible partisanship with this
incredibly adversarial politics where
you have a political system in the
united states that is simply not built
for that which actually demands
consensus because of the extensive
number of checks and balances built into
the system
and yeah i think it is a genuine concern
for the united states that the the
democracy might kind of eat itself and
buckle under the
systemic problems facing up to these
technological and societal problems and
that would be obviously it's a very very
damaging signal to the rest of the
democratic world and also to countries
that
where democracy has yet to take hold and
flourish richard what would a donald
trump as the gop presidential candidate
in 2024 what would that mean for
yeah this inflection point in history
well i mean of course donald trump is a
figure who who very eagerly stokes this
adversarial politics uh stokes this kind
of divisive politics but i think there's
almost a paradox at the moment that we
we've seen under joe biden who's
somebody who really doesn't try to do
that i mean he he essentially uh is seen
as a figure who tries to unite but even
under him this this has not been quelled
the the what we're looking at here
potentially changes in
in american society and politics that
are structural and don't depend
necessarily so much on the individual at
the top
all right so finally for both of you
let's issue this presidential report
card for joe biden enos you first on a
scale we're doing the american way from
an a plus to an f
what grade do you give the president
well
how do we grade the president is it kind
of on a sliding scale
did the president pass two major pieces
of legislation that has major effect on
the united states yes
but has he been able to move any of his
domestic agenda no so it is really
really difficult i would give him an a
because he beat donald trump and he won
the white house but i wouldn't give him
a boring
c
one year in office uh okay so let's all
right we'll we'll take the average of
that and give him a b
then from you enos and richard what
grade would you say biden has earned
well well i i'm i'm just going to duck
that completely
what i am going to say what i'm going to
say that from the international point of
view i mean certainly around the you
know western democracies there really
was this kind of sigh of relief when
biden won office last year a year on
there's definitely
worry about the direction that the
united states is headed in um and i
think i would say one thing if i was a
democratic party uh strategist at the
moment
i would really be hoping that biden
doesn't stand next time around i would
be hoping that it is time for a
transition
a generational transition in the
democratic party at the moment it looks
like a gerontocracy with biden pelosi
and schumer pelosi's on the way out
already uh i think if i was a democrat i
would be saying to biden make way for
the next generation
but he said last night that he would be
running in 2024 with kamala harris as
his vp running mate we will see if he's
able to keep his word on that to both of
you thank you let's do this again in one
year's time we will have the midterm
elections to get through and talk about
in the meantime enos pole richard walker
both of you thank you